stop talking shut your mouth real quick
I'll [ __ ] you up Mac talk [ __ ] talk or
whatever you want to call it the
delicate art of putting someone in their
place with words has always been an
integral part of eSports history so
we're taking a look at some of the best
trash talk from all of these sports
starting with the street savage line
from fighting game pro this can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
not even playin bro I'm sitting here the
whole time talking [ __ ] and if I don't
know that white hair makes me feel a
little bit around him yeah it's just
like why did you go for that but you
know he chose it as a fellow David I
have to respect him so cop good luck
with your hairstyle matter like you're
just mad cause you don't have as much
heimerdinger's open and I sure would
love to see two dongs in action lck game
only with better cuz sometimes prep oh
they have to give you the chance to
actually cast the good team so welcome
to the og an autumn season final it
tastes like the tears of the ocean
[Applause]
smithing is still pretty much dandy
light so okay so dude Smith is just as
good if not a little better so Peter you
didn't make it the world so you're
practicing your stand-up career now
remove you were once a marksman in a DC
and doublet you were once a good ADC so
I do want to I'm just I was talking like
special about just going home right now
what would happen if we just lost I
think we both came up to the conclusion
of it would feel good to come home into
the arms of you know all this hype and
Fame that we've just got it didn't feel
a lot better if we just press these smug
Asians that was the weirdest move I've
ever thought like could ever happen with
dick the last person that I would
replace is scar actually I like going
down the list everybody would be higher
priority to replacement scar I'm more
scared of scars coaching honestly then
dig we're really excited that we stopped
Dignitas in the finals it was the
easiest bottles of our lives of the many
robberies in eSports few are as heated
as the one between Kay Brad and Wolfe
Crohn's so when they face off at the e
League Street Fighter Invitational you
knew things were about to get personal
hey that's a strong word every since
there because I feel like this dude
doesn't win how is he gonna judge me
when I when I actually win tournament
stop talking shut your mouth real quick
so so for one for one second for one
second shut up I'm trying to tell you
that you did something good you idiot
fellow fellows will there ever be any
respect between the two of you guys are
this gonna be an everlasting beef let's
just answer the question as a player I
used to always fist bump him I all used
to always shake his hand until he
started talking trash so it has nothing
to do with the game in the game you're
good you're good you're here you're a
league you made it here you on the big
stage finally you're here but as a
person I just don't like him I just
don't like him straight up
Oh what are your thoughts on that me who
gives a [ __ ]
that's why she's on our team I tried out
top lane for Digg and they didn't want
me so now I knock them out of worlds
feels great as far as I know the only na
team I'm worried about is cloud 9 the
rest are non-existent
especially CEO G to go to bed tonight
thinking I lost the TSM I don't want
that to happen the hotshot hasn't been
singing for the last three years
I hope Team Liquid can have a perfect
record against TSM [ __ ] on them in the
finals if they make it there
I want to absolutely demolished TSM's
legacy and make sure that they regret
that decision the world championships
cold out biggest event of the year
definitely something I want to get my
second ring in you know I have two more
than they shot but you know
if you play fanatic what can we expect
from that matchup down the lane Assam
that's what you can expect but one sided
stops like me and I four really good and
like I said I think reckless kind of
overrated
Kenny s he said that he wanted to face
you guys in the finals and he was very
very company has some choice words there
I say so what are your words for Kenny s
to G to who you're gonna be facing off
against tomorrow
good luck Kenny I'll [ __ ] you up oh dear
God so you guys think as a sport will
challenge you guys in a couple weeks any
game you want you come to any game not
make you eat those words buddy cuz it's
get back well first or the analyst desk
have nothing like to worry about they
can talk about all the problems we're
having with the video some blah blah
blah whatnot they don't have they don't
know [ __ ] if you ask me especially
touring North America has always liked
behind Europe and counterstrikes
but when Team 3d managed to take down n
IP in the semi-finals of the
championship gaming Invitational Jaguar
led up the now iconic battle cry of all
NACS fans
[Applause]
now what was it like just beating the
team that gave you the boot a few weeks
ago
it was like taking candy from a baby I
think I deserve it
honestly this is just practice you've
never ever lost a major tournament
you're going up against completely they
have the upper hand now what you're
gonna do differently whose complexity a
lot of people are gonna hate me for this
but I feel like Turkey is at least three
times easier in group a could you maybe
elaborate because you just hit on ozone
but is there any other team you target
with that statement or everybody all
right how good is it to get a pentakill
at the LCS all-stars LCS all-stars it
technically was Europe versus North
America everyone else's trash any team a
particular any player that you're really
looking forward to playing against dar
doc how do you fit so many people in
your backpack
I think the Koreans are pretty light
what sort of adjustments did you make to
your game in order to beat him finally
six games total download complete
I've heard some rumors going around that
the real reason that you are back in the
North American LCS is to avoid running
into cutie-pie in soloqueue can you
provide me with other or not there's any
truth to that
no Katie Phi is busy garbage there you
go ladies and gentlemen the truth has
come out he can use mask I'm glad this
guy works for NASA because I'm gonna
slap his ass to the moon and when you
heard that Michael men would be taking
his spot what then did you think easy
money
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button